what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday we got the
very first trailer for she-hulk so in
this video i'll explain everything you
need to know about what we saw in the
trailer who exactly is jennifer walter
she hulk how did she get her powers who
were all those people that we saw in the
trailer we actually saw multiple
different villains and of course we have
to talk about other characters making
appearances like daredevil and i'll also
give you my thoughts on the trailer and
we'll start with that because i do need
to address the fact that the cgi was not
very good it's actually kind of funny
because i put out some tweets and
instagram posts asking everybody what
they thought of the trailer and i
watched it on my phone for the first
time and a lot of people started
commenting wow the cgi is really bad so
i went to my computer and i watched it
and i was like wow it actually is pretty
bad but the question is will they make
it any better for the actual show
because this is just the trailer they do
have time to improve it before the show
actually comes out however i'm not sure
they actually will because if they
thought it was good enough for the
trailer they probably think that it's
good enough for the show however maybe
if they monitor comments which i know
they do on all of their platforms they
may read all the comments saying that
the cgi is bad and might try to change
it but again since they thought it was
good enough for the trailer this might
be the final cgi that we see in the
series but we'll have to wait and see
now she-hulk looks like it has the
potential to actually be a good show and
a very hilarious show there's rumors
that she's going to be breaking the
fourth wall in the show much like
deadpool does in his movies and if
executed properly that could be pretty
funny and she-hulk is a pretty prominent
and important character in the comics
she's been a member of the avengers the
fantastic four the defenders fantastic
force heroes for hire and shield and she
was a part of secret wars which we do
know the mcu is leading up to and we are
in sort of a comic accurate marvel phase
right now and in one of the first scenes
that we see of her as she-hulk she jumps
to the floor and we see her in a very
comic accurate suit although she doesn't
fully turn around and we don't see her
facing this but the suit is taken right
from the comics now as far as how she
actually becomes she-hulk it looks like
they are going to be changing up her
origins just a little bit here in the
comics jennifer walters gets shot by a
crime boss but on that same day her
cousin bruce banner aka the hulk who
does actually say cuz in the trailer he
just so happened to be visiting her on
that same day to tell her about his hulk
transformation jennifer ends up needing
a blood transfusion to stay alive and
bruce banner her cousin is the only one
there with the same blood type so bruce
banner gives his cousin jennifer walters
his blood and of course as we know his
blood is filled with gamma radiation he
gives her gamma irradiated blood and
this causes her to become she-hulk now
this explains why professor hulk who we
see here is so involved with her in this
teaser trailer he's helping her adapt
and stay in control of her hulk form the
she-hulk now i don't think she actually
is going to get shot they show a car
crash in the beginning of this trailer
so it is possible that she gets into a
really really bad car accident and
that's when bruce banner comes in and
gives her some of his blood from there
on out it looks like she turns into the
hulk but bruce takes her back to an
island which appears to be where he
lives so we can kind of just hulk out
and be whoever he wants and not be
disturbed most likely taking her back
there as well so she can learn to do
hulk things but not damage anything
around her plus not to mention the hulk
is a scientist he's a genius when it
comes to this sort of stuff jennifer is
insanely smart as well but she is a
lawyer not a scientist so this is
bruce's expertise and that's where we
sort of see all these experiments with
professor hulk trying to teach her how
to be in control now something worth
noting is that this is still indeed
professor hulk if you recall in the
shanghai and the legend of the ten rings
post credits scene we actually saw bruce
banner no longer in hulk form he wasn't
the hulk he wasn't professor hulk he was
bruce banner so that leads me to believe
that she-hulk probably takes place
before the events of chongqi but this
does of course take place after the
events of avengers in-game because bruce
banner is professor hulk now because she
turns into the hulk because of the blood
transfusions she gets from her cousin
her hulk form is a more mild version of
bruce banners this is why she's able to
walk around as she-hulk and still kind
of be the same person jennifer walters
the lawyer now what's interesting is
that in the comics her she-hulk form was
originally explained as being molded by
her subconscious thoughts and desires to
look like the ideal woman according to
her own thoughts and eventually she
would go on to choose to retain her
she-hulk form permanently because she
preferred the freedom and the confidence
that it gave her and they kind of tease
at that a lot in this teaser trailer we
see her posing for her friends we hear
the women talking about how good her
butt looks we even see her going on
tinder and seeing all of the guys that
like her and eventually it looks like
she finds a guy that likes to be tossed
around good for you man no judgment here
do your thing now the trailer of course
tells us that she is a lawyer and that's
kind of the subtitle of the series she
hulk attorney at law and this is why
it's heavily rumored that daredevil is
going to be making an appearance in the
show for more than one episode and that
just makes sense because he is also a
lawyer also in new york they've run into
each other a lot in the comics and it
would make sense that they would run
into each other in the mcu especially
because the two of them represent
superheroes now in the beginning of this
trailer her boss tells her that they
just started a superhuman law division
in her law firm and he wants her to be
the head of it now before he says this
they show us a very very large facility
we also see her walk out of this
facility which seems to be heavily
guarded so i'm assuming that this
facility is a prison for super humans
kind of like the raft which we saw in
captain america civil war and in this
prison we see tim roth back as emil
blonsky aka abomination we see him
talking to jennifer walters and he's
inside of some type of cage now this
looks pretty similar to the cage that
nick fury and shield made for the hulk
in the first avengers film so maybe this
is a sword facility but we actually saw
this in shanghai when wang and
abomination are about to leave wang
opens up a portal and we see some place
that shows us this exact same cage that
we're seeing here in this trailer now
why were abomination and wong putting on
a fight show we're not sure but
hopefully we'll find out in this series
and marvel did confirm that wang is
going to be appearing in the series now
we are briefly shown two new people in
this trailer one is a villain and one is
kind of a smaller hero in the comics not
sure if he'll remain a hero in the mcu
we'll have to see but the first one is
titanium we see her fighting with
jennifer walters aka she-hulk in the
courtroom what i'm imagining here is
that jennifer walters is going against
her in a court case and most likely ends
up winning the case which makes titania
angry and that results in a fight now
titania is going to be played by actress
jamila jamil and this is actually going
to be a very very interesting character
because in the comics titania gets her
powers from doctor doom during the
secret wars event she gets pulled into
battle world in which doctor doom finds
her and her sister and they agreed to
serve doctor doom and he gives them
powers in return you see titania was
bullied when she was a kid and she often
dreamed about having superpowers so she
could get back at the people who picked
on her so she takes this opportunity to
get superpowers and basically her
superpowers enhance all of her strength
she gets taller she gets bigger and it's
like her body is basically resistant to
almost anything titania's body is highly
resistant to physical energy she will
withstand high caliber bullets
temperature extremes she can fall from
great heights and she can take severe
blunt force trauma so she'll be quite
the match for she-hulk and i'm really
curious to hear about her origins and if
they do connect to doctor doom now we
did see one more person in this very
briefly who kind of looks like the green
power ranger at least at first glance at
second glance this is frogman not a very
well-known marvel superhero from the
comics although he has teamed up with
spider-man before and helped him his
father originally created the frogman
suit that had supercharged coils that
help him leap into the air about six
stories high eventually his dad went to
jail but he took the costume and he took
on the role of a good guy becoming
frogman and it looks like he's going to
play a part in she-hulk now he could be
somebody that jennifer walters is
defending or could be somebody that kind
of just wants to tag along with her
trying to become a superhero and i'm
guessing that there are going to be some
small heroes and small villains that are
introduced all throughout this series
because apparently her trials are going
to deal with superhumans so this series
does have a lot of potential if it's
executed correctly and hopefully the cgi
isn't that bad but go ahead and let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any marvel videos for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof